so we have a paul newman quote here
which reads
don't judge my work by the rules that
were easy where i didn't have to stretch
and explore and expand judge my work by
the roles that challenged me physically
emotionally or spiritually those are the
roles where one false step could bring
down the whole house of cards
so what advice do you have for directors
who have to work with actors who are
taking on one of those challenging roles
hmm well i would say the first thing
is if the director can recognize
that it is that challenging to begin
with that it is going to stretch this
actor a lot i mean this director has
cast this actor in this role obviously
and that it's going to be a big stretch
and it's going to push them
maybe to their limits and all of that
then the next best thing you can do is
again create that safe place for them
they need
a really safe environment with within
which they can stretch and explore
and expand um
into into this role and then i think
that the best thing the director can do
is really be a massive support system
to by your support system i mean
allowing the actor to really
um fall deeply into that character
knowing that the director is always
there to rescue them
save them be a safety net pull them out
not criticize them so that they can go
into those
whatever the extreme areas are and then
one other thing about this because when
i heard paul newman
when he said this at yale when i was
there he said it differently i just
realized when i heard
it again because he was talking about a
lot about
the roles the scripts that were not well
written
and that were really challenging because
there wasn't enough to hold on to
and this may have been what he meant
here with the whole house of cards is
going to fall down if
you don't pull it off now from a
director's side the director is also
going to recognize if that's the
challenge we have here
that's the challenge we have to that we
have a script that's not that strong
it's not that cohesive
and we're we're running a risk like we
are
going to make almost any film that this
film just really is not
going to work and
what i suggest there is that what
they've what has been done
on a lot of films i have a quote for you
since you have a quote
james brooks james l brooks who did as
good as it gets and
a lot of other great films but
in one some panel he was talking on i
was there
he said that his um
fear making a film was knowing that
there's a really good chance i'm gonna
make a
really bad film and his goal was to just
not make
a bad film he's not trying to make a
great film he's trying to not make a bad
film because he's very much aware
of how delicate this whole process is
and how easily it could fall apart
and when they were making as good as it
gets with jack nicholson
it was about a week into the production
that
and this is on the dvd they talk about
it he and jack talk about this
that they realize they didn't know they
weren't clear on how to do
melvin's character this misogynistic
cruel racist human being that
we have to fall in love with eventually
we have to believe that he can fall in
love with someone else eventually
and that's it's a love story and we have
to believe at the end that helen hunt
has fallen in love with him
and jack nicholson and um
james brooks who was one of the writers
on it
had no idea quite how to pull this
off they realized they were in deep
trouble
so their decision was they shot a huge
range of performances on every scene
with jack nicholson
a huge range from being very gentle to
being really brutal
in other words the level of brutality
and callousness and
charm or and humor all of those were
played within every scene a
wide range and they said we'll figure it
out in post-production we'll make the
choices
in post-production and that's another
way that a director can work with an
actress
giving an actor that leeway say listen
i'm
you're in exploring a whole new
territory here i'm going to allow you to
explore
on camera and then in post-production
we'll
we'll make the choices so you don't have
to feel like you have to hit it right
because you don't know what
right is and neither do i and if the
director can admit that and allow the
actor to do that then the actor has more
latitude to work with and more likely to
give
a strong performance
you